gray area with myself
and the woman who currently has the
internet in a Chokehold it is just
pearly things thank you Sarah we have
got a great show for you today today
great area with myself
sorry Bobby and the woman who currently
has the internet in a Chokehold it is
a great show you gotta exit off
thank you
had today guys as you can see from the
title it is virgins versus holds but
before we even get started tell them
you know what I'm saying Pearl tell them
if you have watched two or more of our
videos how many
and you have not subscribed then we have
what Bell beef what we got beef exactly
so you better get doing that right now
over to you Pearl okay guys um a couple
quick announcements before we get
started today
um the first being that we have two
clips channels the first being just
pearly clips and pearl daily where we
just hit 50k and just pearly clips
and we just hit 10K on Pearl daily
um so go subscribe to both of those the
links are in the description um we have
different editing styles on both on top
of that we have four membership tiers
the first being you're able to be a part
of our chat today the second being you
get to see our behind the scenes Vlog of
the pet house which is pretty cool it is
nice it's very nice we're filming that
Saturday so that should be out this week
um the third being you get you get to
connect with us on social media and the
fourth being you get a one-on-one call
with me once a month on top of that
subscribe because we're just about to
hit 350k follow my Instagram I'm almost
at 50k on there that's just dot pearly
things and DM Eddie if you want to come
on the show and they couldn't get rid of
you on you know on Twitter on Tick Tock
yeah okay they took away my first
account on Tick Tock they took away my
second account on Tick Tock they took
away my third account on Tick Tock but I
just hit 100K on just pearlythings.4 and
two weeks in two weeks you can't get rid
of me can't get rid of pale guys in case
they do take away that account because
they might follow just pearly things.5
that's like
because
warning on that account
show for you today we have got some
guests as you guys can already see so
we're gonna go around and you all
introduce yourselves tell us your name
your age your relationship status and a
fun fact about you we'll start this side
uh hello my name is Simona I'm 23.
um I am single and my bands and I are
about to release our first single in
October oh wow yeah you guys should
listen to that
oh that's so fun what kind of music uh
it's rock music like alternative rock oh
cool yeah the hair
you oh um I'm Jamie I'm 35 bit old
um I don't have a fun fact about me I've
done I came really unprepared that's all
right what's what do you do what do you
love doing what do I love doing
gardening gardening as a gardener yeah
yeah but for work I build scaffolding
there you go that's a fun fact
hi I'm Abby um I'm 27 and single and I'm
a fun accountant
she's putting the fun back into
accounting guys
right on my name is Luis Mercado I've
been a YouTuber for a while I'm just
retired as of like two weeks ago so I'm
officially retired
cool I'm Justin Justin Mark uh I'm I
also do YouTube I'm a dating coach on
YouTube and I'm also a club promoter uh
27 years old
nice hi I'm Nina I'm 32 years old and I
put the fun back in fundraising there
you go she's got bars too guys
um okay
whether you guys have seen our content
or not there is a fact that we
we speak about quite a lot and the fact
is one in three men haven't had sex in
the last year and or are virgins
so do you think it is easier for a man
or a woman to lose their virginity
definitely easier for a woman to lose in
Virginia yeah yeah
by far
expand
I mean a guy asked it like a girl can
literally just raise her hand and you
know say who wants to do it with me and
uh a bunch of guys will flock her way
she kind of just doesn't show up right
guys actually have to put in a lot of
work to get laid in general but to go
from like kisses virgin to losing your
virginity and having a girl like you is
a bit of a process
I mean
do you think it's easier for women would
you say
Abby yeah but I think also it depends on
your attractive level
so do you think that
um women losing their virginity depends
on their attractiveness
you get an ugly guy and an ugly woman
he's more likely to leave their
virginity it's hard it's because
obviously
attract uh how attractive you are is
subjective but
I feel like typically attractive women
are obviously going to lose it really
easily but women who aren't your typical
so like I don't know if you're Maybe
overweight or not you're like what your
typical idea of good looking is then
obviously it's going to be harder which
might be on the same level as
I don't know I can't explain it
okay
um you find it you think men will find
it harder to lose a virginity well I
think men would find it hard oh women
yeah
um I think like I'm a 35 year old male
and I haven't thought about losing my
virginity since I was my teenage was it
hard for you no no like really no not at
all like it was just a natural process
of becoming an adult
um yeah like the whole concept to me is
quite foreign
[Music]
to talk to women yeah some guys it's
like not natural to love which is
understandable yeah I mean I think it
can be intimidating it can be but like
no it wasn't for me I grew up with I
grew up in a quite a family with quite a
lot of female with a lot of female
influence and yeah I've never never ever
struggled to talk to women
what do you think
I would say it would be easier for women
to lose their virginity just because
women are probably more selective about
who they sleep with and men are less
because they just kind of want to get
laid but then if you're more selective
wouldn't it be harder generalized uh
well if you're more sexual yeah if
you're more selective wouldn't it be
harder well no because you can afford to
be selective when you have more options
I guess
if that makes sense okay
Collective so men
generalize see how you think women have
more options than men
um I think men are more willing to
overlook
certain things in order to have sex
whereas women won't always do that so A
woman would be more selective in a lot
of Senses they have I guess more
um
I don't want to say standards it's not
about standards but just kind of what
they would want about boundaries
boundaries yeah that's a good word for
it 100 so women have more boundaries
you said
yeah I would I would say that sorry I
would say that there is um there is a
need for women and people people
generally but women to have boundaries
um in order to not fall prey and trap to
um to
labels and titles that come with being
promiscuous I think that there's there's
um
there's a medal behind virginity that
that men kind of want to hold it's like
oh I've lost my virginity I you know I
want to tell everyone about it I don't
feel like there's that much of a medal
behind it for girls it's not like oh
I've let me put a pin in this because I
won I I think it's less of a um
there's not so much incentive for women
to lose their virginity whereas men I I
feel like there's there's more of a come
on you you should do this come on you
should do this come on you should do
this and there's a lot of um toxicity
behind that as well as like
ego that surrounds the type you know the
label virginity as well
so you think that it there was more you
think there's more pressure on women or
men to lose your virginity on men I
would say on men
you think it's on men yes so when you
were like at school when you were
younger like because I mean I remember
me being at school and there was there
was like you're still a virgin oh my God
you're still a virgin
oh my God what are you still doing a
virgin and I think a lot of the time
guys got to the point where they would
just lie about having lost their
virginity like so you didn't have the
same thing as a woman
no and I wouldn't say that um I think
it's really sad that anyone feels like
they have to lie about something in
order to be accepted within
um like peers and friend groups
um and I don't feel like there was that
sort of um
title that comes with losing your
virginity in a female I went to an
all-girl school
um and I don't feel there was any any of
that um where I where I was at school so
even at all girls school there was no
pressure no I didn't did the girl's not
coming and say look I lost my virginity
yeah did they not do that yeah we did
that right okay but there was certainly
no pressure to do that there was no like
you know when are you gonna do it when
are you gonna do it it was a moment of
Pride as and when it happened
um but I don't think it was something
that I don't think it was a necessity
right like I feel like because I went to
Catholic school and I just feel like
people didn't really carry their way as
a girl like if you did cool if you
didn't yeah cool like yeah well you
looked down upon in your school if you
did lose it
um no but it was like hot gossip right
okay like um I went to a small Catholic
school and so like if you heard that
someone like because not a lot of people
really were I know the stereotypes of
Catholic schools but mine was more like
innocent I don't know what's the
stereotype I don't know what's there
I've never heard that like they always
say like Catholic schools are crazy and
I'm sure they are like some of them but
mine was like not like that I don't know
I mean in my experience Church girls
have probably been the freakiest girls
I've ever had sex with I know that it's
like uh but I would just say it was kind
of similar to like a small town where
like if something happens like
everyone's talking about it so you see
you like with virginity do you guys
think that
foreign
do you think that there's a pressure
the pressure to lose your virginity
creates a curiosity that just makes you
want to do it
um is that what happened at your school
uh no I mean I would say maybe more for
men but not as much for women
I would say yeah do you think like The
Virginity nowadays is looked up on with
ridicule if you're a virgin
definitely yeah for a guy or girl anyone
no or both either or
I mean I would say for a guy yeah it's
kind of a little weird you call them in
cells but I would say for a girl if
she's 21 and she actually is a virgin I
think a lot of guys would probably not
believe her but if if they know that to
be a fact they'd probably find that like
really attractive you think so yeah you
think you think a virgin girl is
attractive I mean I think if a girl's
attractive she's attractive attracts to
a man I would say so hmm you were going
to say something you were like nah no
I'm not saying what he said wasn't right
about a guy I find that attractive if
she was 21 and a virgin but I think
all my friends lost their virginity like
at like 14 or something 15 and then I
remember I lost my virginity like a
couple days before my 18th and I
definitely felt like no one directly
pressured me or all my friends weren't
like oh go and do it but it was kind of
like you did feel like a ticking Time
Bomb because it did feel a little bit
like
when everyone's doing one thing if
you're doing something different you
feel a bit weird so it's like when I was
coming up to my 18th it did feel like I
was getting to the weird stage oh really
you felt yeah I felt like awkward like
you have to get it done yeah
but I can't put my finger on where that
come from I guess it's just the norm
because the average um age of people
losing their virginity is actually
around 17. oh okay see compared to like
everyone I know that's really late do
you wonder if
um
those numbers are based on like an older
generation because I just hear stories
from my my younger sisters about like
their friends tell us the stories pal no
no I'm not talking about anything with
minors
sorry no sorry no no no no no
um but I'm there's just wild stories
when they're doing stuff where like like
at a much younger age it seems like than
the older generation so you think
there's more pressure on like the
younger generation to lose it and I
don't even know if it's pressure I just
think they're Wilder like I just think
they're exposed to more younger and I
think that like my mom's generation
would say that about my generation right
like it seems like every generation is
just getting Wilder and Wilder and
Wilder so a lot of times like when I see
the stats it's always based on like five
to ten years ago and I'm like it's a
whole different group of kids so I
remember when I was gonna lose my
virginity I'm not gonna lie as a guy
like I prepared because like you as a
guy you kind of prepare like you know
what's going to happen I knew the day I
had my girlfriend she had already had
sex I hadn't but I never told her that
obviously because I was experienced and
um like you just prepare for it like it
was that the same was it like a was it
something that you kind of fell into or
something you prepare for
for me personally I fell into it oh
really okay yeah it wasn't it wasn't a
preparation it wasn't it was just too
much sorry
um yeah no it wasn't it wasn't yeah I
didn't prepare for it as as you said
yeah but yeah no it just happened
organically you got did you prepare I I
definitely prepared for like a month
like mentally and like spiritually
absolutely prepared uh and like in my
case it was very similar what you're
saying is I didn't want to be the only
one in my friend group was a virgin so I
just found the first girl who had a
crush on me and like just begged her to
let me hook up with her and she was
super enemy so she's like yeah totally
and I prepared for it right because
talking to women was never easy right
right and so yeah it definitely was
something I had to prepare for
how do you prepare for this yes
do you get some condoms and watch
YouTube tutorials by condos
like look for advice on and this is like
over a decade ago right so this is like
yeah it was a long time ago and I I was
just trying to mentally prepare for the
most part and um did it help definitely
definitely I had no idea what I was
doing I just like stuck it in just
waiting for something to happen I was
just confused it was very very confused
as it got better tough
did you have to prepare over there I'm
not married so I couldn't tell you guys
he's a virgin we got a virgin on the
show no I don't know if I like prepared
but yeah it kind of just happened but I
already kind of was wanting it to happen
actually the very first time I had the
option to do it it I couldn't make it
happen I was like too nervous and the
girl was older than me she wanted to and
I just couldn't
right not being descriptive here but uh
yeah I just couldn't get hard I was like
too nervous I was really young yeah like
really young how young really young I
think I was like a freshman in high
school I don't know how well that is
over here um 14. no I was like 12 or 13.
yeah yeah girls had crushes on me when I
was young and then um but yeah it was
until later it was probably like a year
and a half two years later
after that wow wow
I was trying to get laid at that age I
really
we go to Catholic school and I feel like
the girls would feel guilty like after
if they lost their virginity to be
honest like just in my friend group I
guess
so that's what God like I definitely did
because I was older I was definitely the
last one in my friend group but like I
felt so guilty because I felt like God
was like mad
I'm still mad but no I know I know he's
still bad so
that pressure at 12 so I just want to
kind of Flesh it out like where did you
think that came from like where did it
because at 12 to me a 12 year old would
be thinking about different things other
than sex I was probably like 13. she was
a junior so she was probably like 15 or
16. she was just like an older girl to
me like the a year or two makes a
difference in high school right you know
and then she was like she's already done
it she was experienced I wasn't so she
was like 14. her she was probably like
15 or 16 I don't know yeah okay yeah
um I don't know you're just never done
it you're nervous you hear about it you
see all these adult films and you're a
kid and you're like yeah back then
actually we didn't have the internet
like you know I'm 34 I forgot to mention
earlier but I remember like when we were
in elementary school someone found this
adult magazine right from their dad and
they ripped out a page so we used to
have to walk home from the bus stop and
there was like this desert where we'd
hide this one picture just a still
picture of a girl with her boobs and
like we were all like young kids staring
at this thing and we'd hide it back
under this rock throw dirt on it and
like we'd stop by there like every day
to look at it so do you think like your
introduction to like losing The
Virginity was probably not healthy was
something like that like because I think
a lot of guys like even me like I had I
was introduced to like a corn videotape
when I was like 13. that blew my mind so
young to me
no literally like like I had a friend
and he was at his house and he knew he
was older than me he was like 15. I was
like 13. and
he knew that his mother had like a corn
video that's his VHS times like she had
like a VHS and he was like guys there
was like three of us and I was like guys
I'm going to show you something and um
he put the tape on and that at that at
13 that literally blew my mind yeah one
of the greatest days of My Teenage life
was fun
like everything changed so I have a
question for the guys
um would you want to marry a virgin
definitely yes yeah
absolutely I mean it's not the end-all
thing but if it's uh if I found the girl
and I was gonna like it regardless I
mean then yeah that's just I would say
would you guys be willing to like wait
then until you're married to sleep with
her
ooh
that's usually what comes with a virgin
like if if she's she's usually waiting
so like typically
um like my friends that were virgins
when they got married like the dude
dated them for a year a year and a half
then they got married so he didn't do
anything with anyone else for a year
year and a half
it's an interesting question because
like personally I just don't think
marriage is advantageous I'm from Canada
right and so the family court system
they're just not in the benefit of men
so I just don't believe in marriage but
I think my ideal partner that I want to
like kind of like emotionally
spiritually settle down with you know
ideally would have a lower body count
what what if um maybe marriage it
doesn't have to be like marriage in the
church sure because like those girls
typically want to get married in the
church sure yeah I mean would you be
willing to wait like a year year and a
half to be with that girl I think so
yeah okay are you being honest though
like okay the only reason I ask is
because a lot of guys like say they want
virgins but I don't think they want what
would come with it and I know a lot of
girls that are virgins and did wait till
they were married because I went to
Catholic school and just like different
churches I've been involved in I'm like
I don't think a lot of the guys that say
they want virgins would do the stuff
they'd be like they would want I mean
talk about your ex-girlfriend yeah if
you can yeah talk about us girlfriend
um yeah my ex-girlfriend was a virgin
when I met her okay
um so it's not like and is she still a
virgin no I I took that okay fair enough
yeah yeah
yeah but um I don't know I'm kind of on
board with what Justin was saying about
the whole marriage system like I'd want
to do in the church for her and you know
have the big party and you know give her
the memories and whatnot but in terms of
like actually signing a legal binding
contract to a government I that doesn't
really interest me too much yeah no I
agree I don't think it's advantageous
for men like if I was a guy I probably
wouldn't want to get married
um but it's interesting that what you
say about guys wanting a virgin but not
being willing to wait for the virginity
like that's like yeah a year and a half
sounds like a long time it does that
means we'd have to bump that marriage up
but do you think do you think that's
because you've experienced sex already
um
probably
um yeah so now you know what it is you
know what you're going to be missing
right yeah
and I think that's a lot of what
because uh remember last show we had
Linda on and she was a virgin and
um I was speaking to her after the show
and it's just interesting
the way guys are like if
we speak at a statistics right and
marriages often work out if the two
people that get together in a marriage
are are virgins yeah it's like the the
highest
the success rate is when they're both
virgins yeah yeah so if one has already
experienced sex and the other one hasn't
their marriage is less likely to work
out
yeah I believe that that makes sense
why are you laughing sorry because that
makes no sense to me whatsoever oh
really why tell me why
because like
I'm like why would she even like I just
I wouldn't have even consider someone
how how many like if someone's a virgin
or not if I like I I don't bump into any
of you and say hey are you a virgin no
but when you're getting to know somebody
you would ask a question though
you don't want to know if the woman that
you're with is a virgin or she's had sex
with a hundred thousand men like
so you would marry a girl that had sex
with a hundred guys
uh wow like why why is the number like I
I'm yeah sorry I just yeah that's a
completely abstract concept to me do you
want to talk about pair bonding bro no
it was because I only got like yeah I
only discovered who you were yesterday
and yeah like yeah and like even the the
idea of that yeah whatever bonding is
intriguing to me because it's a
completely foreign concept okay
it's just in my entire life yeah it's
just basically like the more partners
that a girl
um has the more people she Compares him
to typically and it makes her less
satisfied with the guy she's with so for
example if a girl is a virgin when she's
married she has an 80 chance of having a
happy marriage after 10 years where if
she slept with more than five people it
drops to a 30 chance how are you how are
you describing these statistics to that
like what's the like how how do you
possibly prescribe an 80 statistical so
they they survey the people later
so like how many people did you slept
with when you got when you got married
and then later they come back and ask if
they're happy are they reducing that to
just sex and saying that the reason the
women are comparing them to the Past man
is specifically because of sexism well
okay they don't they don't they they
don't say in the study that it's because
they compare so I should say that's just
like based on like my like talking to
people
um it's just based on how many partners
they've had so it drops down to 25
percent it's just very harmless Simpson
telling Kent Brockman that like 40 of
all people can make up statistics like
so yeah so you don't see the you don't
see the sense in it so if if you think
that somebody has experienced a hundred
men for instance yeah if a woman's
experienced 100 men yes and then you're
101. yeah you don't think that those 100
men would
um she won't think about one of those
100 men
and not you and not you of course you
would but right exactly so that's that
but but that that it's complete it's it
does it's a it's a fallacy it doesn't
like it it's not a comparable statistic
well well of course it is because do you
know what an alpha Widow is a what Alpha
Widow an alpha Widow yeah so uh a lot of
women a lot of women have gone Pearl
you'll explain it better than I would
well it's basically like like women like
to be with a guy that's the best that
they can get
and like they want to feel like they're
with who the best the best that they can
get and the problem is if a girl has a
guy that's at a certain caliber and then
she goes on to date somebody else and
she sees him as settled so a lot of
times women sleep up
and then the person that they marry
isn't who they actually want and so
there's like accounts of like like even
there's Reddit threads of like girls
talking about how they you know married
one guy and they miss their husband or
not sorry they miss their ex-boyfriend
from college or whoever it was but what
is why does sex or how many people
they've slept with determined that
wouldn't it be other factors
if you've had a hundred guys but not all
of those are going to be substantial
relationships not all those are going to
be comparable to say the person you're a
specific person you're always no
different for one person sleeping with
one person and comparing that to that
person right what do you do so and so
say if they um had only slept with say
like five people before they met the
person they married right
um regardless of whether they slept with
a hundred or five there's still that one
boyfriend that they'd compare to you're
actually you're actually correct with
that it's not it's not necessarily only
about the number like if you know the
first person you slept with was Michael
B Jordan I think it's going to be hard
to live up with up to that if that's
your first boyfriend so it's not
necessarily about the number but when
you go up to a hundred it's like the the
more chances of there being a guy that
you can't live up to I think increases I
think if women are actually honest they
all know that one guy in their head that
they probably won't say there's that one
guy that they know who we're actually
talking about I don't know who he is but
you do I think it's it's depending on
how you view your past relationships for
me there's not one in my life I would
really want to go back to because I
understand why it didn't work out and
and it worked out didn't work out for
specific reasons and I'm not quite
frankly that person anymore and I also
think it's dependent on the
circumstances of how women are sleeping
with these different men right if
they're not entering into emotional
commitments or you know why they're
sleeping around these sorts of things
and then they change the headspace that
they're in then I don't think body count
has an impact on who their future
partner might be based on just oh like
self-awareness question what value does
more bodies bring to a guy
does it have to bring value yeah no I'm
saying I'm saying I'm saying when when a
girl Banner biologically
predispositioned to be attracted to
Purity and youth what do you mean by
that like throughout throughout all of
history like the most powerful men had
concubines of virgins right but like so
so that's something yeah
I'm saying you can't I'm saying uh
Genghis Khan yeah but I would attribute
that to the claiming of power
I would say that would be attributed to
men wanting or people in those positions
one is claiming as much power as
possible and the more most power you can
have is over a submissive pure female
right it doesn't necessarily right but
I'm saying like we're they're attracted
to Youth and Purity and they can't undo
that but that's that's a power based
mindset right and that power is what we
kind of crave through a survival mindset
right when we're trying the person who
has the most power is the most likely to
survive right and so when we're in that
frame of mind that makes sense but
that's not the world that we kind of
really live in anymore it's not really
based around survival it's not based
around this calling for power I don't
think that should be the
um the defining right a factor in terms
of right but that's like a woman's point
of view right you might you might not
think that but in general guys care and
so it's like you can't go to the market
and tell them and I know I know your
friend doesn't and like but this is an
exception but it's about the rules he's
that much of an exception I bet a lot of
people who don't really care and don't
really consider that because there are
other factors they consider are they
trying to sleep with you who like the
people that told you that in terms of
they don't
those guys are here right so guys you
prefer a purer woman than more of a hoe
absolutely yeah and there's a lot of
factors when it comes like in a girl but
I think if the exact same girl and then
she slept with a thousand men or three
men
yeah you're going to want the girl who
has had less men inside of her right
even if even if I were to say that there
was any weight on body count I would say
you'd have to consider that the
circumstances that that body count
happened and right where that person was
at why they were sleeping around right
and what space they might be in right so
guys will completely change their habits
but guys I don't think that's true I
don't believe that's true I think that
is actually kind of making too much of a
generalization I know you work on the
job
but that is too much it's it's a lot
more nuanced than that I don't think as
many men as you think actually I'm just
saying if a woman came to me and said
I've slept with a thousand men because I
was broken and I had been abused and
blah blah blah right you still slept
with a thousand men where's the
compassion in that though where's
where's that's what I'm not thinking
about I'm thinking about you've had a
thousand penises inside you're going to
be with someone shouldn't compassion be
a main factor in that relationship right
an understanding of who they are of what
they've been through shouldn't it
yeah the world doesn't owe you
understanding like that's entitlementing
you're not you're not entitled to
someone's compassion and understanding
and that you I think men are allowed to
be selective in who they date and like I
think men are allowed to have standards
and if that's their standard so be it
and it's not it's not every single guy
but I think in general if you pull men
would you rather have a girl that slept
with a hundred or slept with one they
would pick one and and I are they less
picky than they were a hundred years ago
sure you were a hoe If you slept with
three people 100 years ago right right
so are they less picky now sure but you
can't undo the wiring What What In
general men want
so where would you say that's come from
in terms of them wanting that where
would you be because
I'll tell you where is that so
historically historically they had to
ensure paternity yeah so historically
like a man a man did not want to pass on
resources to a kid that was not theirs
so they're biologically predispositioned
to be grossed out by hoes you know
basically yeah because it's like well
whose child is that it's not mine it
could be like it could be Stanley's and
Derrick's do you know I mean he doesn't
know and so you're trying to I hate what
you're saying but you can't undo the
biological wiring that human beings have
had for centuries thousands of years it
just is what it is can we can we put a
marker on where this historic number is
coming from you're saying 100 years ago
that was 1922.
between World War one and World War II
and in what part like like it's a very
it's a very vague argument you're saying
you're saying historically a hundred
years ago well you could you could take
um data from like the 1950s where the
majority of high school graduates were
actually virgins before like the whole
birth control was introduced in the
sexual Revolution like happen in the U.S
because um so that was wasn't actually
invented by that like yeah you're right
like I'm not saying like women a women
it gave women the option to sleep around
but that's what I'm saying back then it
was like um it was bad like it was
looked down upon if you had more than a
certain amount of sex partners and you
can even think of this anecdotally like
if I start telling my mom about that if
I start telling my mom about the body
counts like of girls nowadays she's
disgusted she's like what on Earth is
going on I tell my grandma I tell I tell
my grandma
I tell my grandma about like the body
counts nowadays she's like what is going
on in these streets and we could just
say like anecdotally and me when I hear
like my little sister with the stories
that they tell me I'm like what on Earth
but it's like every generation go ahead
in America right now uh
100 of women that enter the college
system run 17 right only 12.3 lead
virgins
only 12.3 lead for college virgins wait
you give me a 100
you got a hundred percent of women
entering the college education system
and when you leave the college education
system only 12.3 percent of virgins
what's that statistic for men
for women so what's that statistic for
men though 4.4.5 4.5 live
and 12. sorry 14.5 14 points and 12.5
12. 12.3 so we were talking a difference
of like one and a half two percent so so
what happens during the College Years
now in in these days and times is people
are definitely more promiscuous in the
most formative years of their life when
they're supposed to be going out and
experiencing new experiences so so okay
so then we have this whole it's a
misnomer though right it's completely so
do you do you think Society benefits
from promiscuity or it doesn't benefit
from promiscuity I think it's completely
irrelevant you think promiscuity is
completely irrelevant I think whether it
benefits Society or not is irrelevant I
don't think like you're I don't think
that it should be a definitive enough as
like one person 100 people 1 000 people
it is a benefit or not to society you
can't prescribe statistics yeah it's
just like you can't we go on 12.4 of
this because it's it's it's relevant
subjective to each individual individual
and their own bodily autonomy okay but
do you do you think it's do you think
it's good for families that people are
sleeping around more
in what sense like do you think it's
good to go into a marriage with a bunch
of exes
is that is that good like and I just say
this from from experience because my
parents have only been with each other
and like where I would see you know Exes
come back in the picture and like some
of my friends parents marriages and like
other stuff come in where my parents had
like only been with each other and I
think it was better for their marriage
and that's completely subjective you
it's completely it's it's well you could
say that but when you also have data to
back it up right I would say there's
other factors that go into that and I
kind of bring back what I said about
them having a certain amount of
self-awareness right when you choose to
go into marriage I think people have to
take accountability for their pasts and
acknowledge you know where they're maybe
still holding on to things before you
enter into a big commitment like that
and I don't think you know the number of
your body count or the number of people
you've been with prevents you from being
able to do that I feel like you can
still make the choice to do that you
have to make the choice to do that but I
think it's independent of your body
count and I think even if you slept with
a number of people if you have the
self-awareness to be able to say this is
what I'm still holding on to these are
the people I'm still holding on to this
is why it didn't work out I'm choosing
to move forward with that that's a
choice and you can actively make that
choice consciously right you're right
and that's why it's not a hundred
percent yeah but I'm saying like every
person you sleep with brings more
baggage to the next relationship you can
learn to release that baggage you know
what I mean
you can but I don't think most women do
then I think the conversation should be
about how how do we when you say that
people don't owe you understanding
compassion I would actually disagree
with that because I would say at a base
as humans we owe each other
understanding we always tell their
empathy we owe each other acceptance so
that we can actually work towards the
middle ground on these issues and find a
way through instead of kind of just
placing the blame and pushing people
into a space where they have to
victimize themselves and and struggle to
take accountability because they're
constantly being attacked for it you
know what I mean so but I think
accountability comes with being honest
and I just think it's dishonest to say
there's no consequence for sleeping
around and like most men will be lined
up to date you even if you slept with a
hundred people like that's dishonest but
I don't and I think it's lying to a
younger generation of women when we
should tell them to be more pure and
protect that more sleeping around brings
more abortions
right yes or no yeah right it brings
more depth amongst babies people killing
their babies it brings more sexual
transmitted diseases so like I was
saying is being from mothers single
mothers also like I said is it better
for society or not and and you're saying
that promiscuity or some people here are
saying promiscuity
it doesn't matter but it does because it
affects Society it creates single
mothers it creates dead dead children
and it also it does and it creates uh
sexual transmitted diseases don't men
not putting condoms on like create
babies as well as women or like or women
not using them for or women not using
the 41 forms of birth control that are
available to them
there's like too many options tonight if
a woman gets pregnant it's on her yeah
because you can also require that the
men you sleep with wear condoms you can
make that a requirement so I would say
it's like on the women if you get
pregnant it's like kind of your own
fault because I think I think as a woman
I do take it on myself because obviously
I don't want to get pregnant but I don't
think it's all in the woman I think it's
definitely 50 50. I I tell you I'll give
you my opinion wise I think it's on a
woman because
unless it's a grape situation you let
him inside you okay and you have
remember my body my choice right that's
what we're told so it's your body so
it's your choice to let a man inside you
right and you know the consequences of
letting a man inside you
yes or no right so so this man could be
Reckless it's just like this home I if
if we let somebody in the door right now
and they run in here and they go crazy
right that's on us because we let them
in we didn't vet them properly before we
let them in right so if you didn't vet
the person properly before you let them
in that's on you that's what they're
gonna say okay so if I choose that I
don't want to be on the pill or all the
other options and I decide that I want
you to wear a condom and then you don't
wear a condom is that on me as well
what I'm saying is if you trust you
you're already having sex so there's
already a sense of trust between you
so obviously I don't know I'm just given
a random example if it is in the dark or
whatever
and you do it yeah
stealth thing is like a minuscule
percentage of what happens during sex
and my question no it was more miles and
well no my question is like why didn't
you vet the guys better you're sleeping
with you shouldn't be sleeping with a
guy you don't trust why don't you vet
any of us I did I'm saying in this
particular example you did trust that
person and you have and so it's also he
could he can lie so I might have felt
like I'd vetted him well enough to be in
that position but obviously you find out
later it's not the truth what percent do
you feel like that is do you feel like
that's the majority
no not at all I was actually just asking
what your opinion was in that particular
scenario I think when when we have these
conversations what people generally tend
to do is to try to bring the exceptions
more so than the rule and it's like
normally on the show we try to argue the
rule more so than the exception because
there's always going to be there's
always going to be exceptions to things
right so it's like okay
dogs bark some dogs have got something
wrong with their you know their their
boys they don't but generally dogs bark
do you know what I mean so it's like if
people keep arguing for the dogs that
don't bark it's like well dogs bark we
already know dogs bark well and I would
say I would still say it's on you
because you chose not to be on birth
control
women don't go on birth control yeah but
there's 41 forms of birth control so and
if you don't want to do that you can get
married
I think it's actually the guy's fault if
the girl gets pregnant go for it because
no it's the guy's fault because I mean
the even the pull-up method alone is 97
effective when done right so unlike
unless you want to be paying child
support like you should get better that
and then the other thing is like guys
should always carry condoms you know I I
because you never know when you get
lucky right but but my thing is like I
can do everything right and a girl can
still steal it like the NBA issue
statements every year they don't do
everything right what he didn't do
everything right you should flush that
thing take it with you when you leave
yeah good point so I think yeah if I had
a son I would tell him hey if a girl
gets pregnant it's one million percent
your fault if I had a daughter I'd say
if you get pregnant it's one million
percent your fault and everybody that
whether a boy or girl it's 100 your
responsibility what happens in your life
I just I think it's more on the girl
because we have more power right we have
like we have more power than men do in
every instance and and if we get
pregnant we can still get an abortion
where men have no say in that and if the
child is born you can put it out for
adoption yeah that's on that's not a man
doesn't have a say a man doesn't have a
say in one whether or not and so I don't
know how you men generally has to say
but it just doesn't make any sense
because the way the law works
it's still going to be the guy's
responsibility as well like and the
girls both of them individually I'm not
saying as a man that we don't have
responsibility I'm not taking
responsibility off demand I'm saying
you've got to protect your womb you are
head of security for your own vagina
right because we know that push comes to
shove
you're left with a baby a guy could run
to he could dip out which is why girls
are more selective when choosing
Partners right traditionally right
exactly I'm saying that's why it's on
you because I'm not condoning men like
running away from their responsibilities
by the way but I'm saying worse comes to
worse it's on you girl
it's not on me I can deep out so that's
why I said women have to now start
vetting the men that are coming inside
them it's a smart choice to that yeah
you know
yeah
it looked like you wanted to say a lot
earlier yeah yeah go ahead well no I'm
just thinking like
so I I've got an ex-girlfriend's of mine
pregnant and I just once like many many
times and every single time it's like
100 been my fault right I was like young
or drunk or just like being unsafe or I
trusted what the woman was telling me
one time uh I had a one eight stand in
Australia and she told me she was on
birth control turns out she was lying
right or had an ex-girlfriend who told
me she has a medical issue she can't get
pregnant and you know she actually got
pregnant and every single one of them
got abortions but regardless it was not
just traumatic for me it was traumatic
for them obviously but in the end it was
completely my fault because I was being
young and dumb and Reckless
well I'm I've gone back to how many
women
my head is spinning I said but but
you've also just held yourself
accountable to all of that
I I don't think it's entirely my fault
no no but
um
completely hold yourself accountable and
like all right yeah I don't not believe
in accountability like I think that's
great I just think at this point in time
like women have more power when it comes
to reproduction I agree and so that's
why because they're the only ones that
have worms
right exactly so be careful did you let
inside there
because I don't have a womb
and all the women here do right so if
all the women here have wounds they have
to be more careful because like I said
worse comes to worse you were saying you
got drunk and you had sex with this girl
but she
let you inside her drunk and she lied
yeah and that's what I'm saying like she
had more power in that situation because
she got the pick if she was on birth
control or not and then she was able to
lie to you and basically trick you it's
true and so like how can you say you had
more power in that situation you should
have known better she was a stranger
right like she was a complete stranger I
just met this girl right I don't
remember her name and so what so what
stopped what's stopping me from having
intercourse with the girl and saying
I've had a vasectomy nothing nothing so
like so that which completely shifts the
Power Balance because one is more
accessible than the other one is much
more accessible than the other 41 forms
of birth control you speak of yeah yeah
so that's more excessive that's more
accessible and you don't have to get
surgery to get it there are a lot of
side effects to birth control though
especially hormonal especially if you
kind of have predisposition to hormonal
imbalance it can cause a lot of negative
side effects even the non-hormonal ones
can cause like really like a lot of pain
like a lot of discomfort and that sort
of thing so the choice to not be on
birth control can actually like yeah the
fact that there's a lot of difficulties
with being on birthday I I understand
that and I'm not discounting that like I
think there's a lot of reasons to not be
on birth control but my thing is like we
have more power when it comes to
reproduction because even if you do get
pregnant who has the power to get an
abortion we do
and even even if we have the kid who is
the power to give it up for adoption we
do and even if even if we keep the kid
who has the power to get get a guy on
child support we do and then who who
also has the option to get married to
the guy and then leave and take half you
do
so like when it comes to reproduction we
just don't have power much power when it
comes to reproduction
they they they can ejaculate
you don't think there's some like um
hang on sorry
articulate that
just articulate that's what we want to
articulate you can say it's absurd but
articulated the entire argument to
complete logical fallacy you're arguing
that like what the women have more power
because they have reproductive organs
that's like it like it doesn't it
doesn't make any sense like if you're
speaking from the perspective of a man
though you don't have a womb of course I
am but that I I was the one that raised
that point earlier right exactly I'm not
the egg like I like so if you speak to
women and ask women do that dude after
we've actually had this argument do they
think that they have more power than we
do would you say yes or no what what
kind of no no I'm asking the women like
do you think you have more power than us
when it comes to reproduction it's a
question like do you as a woman do you
think you have more power when it comes
to reproduction than men do as in a baby
being born so you and you're talking
about power as in like power to get the
to keep the baby not have the baby get
the baby fostered or addicted or
um I think that that power's been put on
women
um I think that there's like a lot you
know bringing up the womb womb people
letting people in the womb but your
sperm should be quite you know quite
important in this so the question I
asked was do women have more power than
men like do women have the final say
yeah no no so men have the final say so
it's not your body your choice anymore I
don't I don't I think it's I think when
it comes to a baby it's it takes two to
tango and I think that there's two
people who have made this baby two
people have a decision to make together
as to what's in the best interest of the
the two people and the possible baby
okay so so using that I'll say okay so
it's two to tango okay you get pregnant
I have sex with you you get pregnant I
say
I don't want a baby great me neither
know what I'm saying me saying that do I
have the power to stop it yes yes I
don't have the power to stop you from
having a child
because it's your body your choice you
can choose I can't I can't choose to get
rid of that baby for you yeah otherwise
you can do that yeah otherwise every man
would be getting rid of accidental
pregnancy exactly I have a question for
you
um would you be okay with men being able
to sign off their rights as a father
um because we have the right to get an
abortion yes so you'd be okay with like
them being able to sign off financially
I think that both people should be able
to do that if it's consented and
communicated any like people should be
able people should be able to do so even
if women like want to keep the kid you'd
be cool with that yes okay like at least
what about you guys what do you think I
feel like you can do I feel like there
is a way that you can sign off your uh
not necessarily you can though it
depends where you're at but not
necessarily it's not quite interesting
in some places that is already a thing
because I do agree I think both people
have the option to decide how involved
they're going to be in a child's
upbringing and if someone doesn't want
to be a part of that then there's it's
not a good idea to force them right and
what about child support you'd be okay
with them being able to sign off and
um
yes I think if two people have had this
baby accidentally there's a good chance
that they're independent anyway so kind
of relying on your own kind of
independent source of income you know to
have a baby and stuff like that
especially if you're the one choosing
the other person isn't then yes I think
that's fair okay what do you think
I can give my own anecdotal even a
anecdotal evidence with like my my
biological father wanted to have me
aborted and him and my mother were quite
young and they didn't yeah didn't get
along and
my mother made her choice and it was it
was Grand and I've lived to be a happy
adult and I've caught up with my
biological father many times and he's
fine but I don't have a I don't have a
continuous ongoing relationship with him
and it's completely fine like it's not
like like yeah it hasn't affected me I'm
in the slightest like yeah okay what do
you think
um I agree that they should be able to
sign off because yeah because I've got
friends that have been gone pregnant
while a guy they're not with in a
relationship with he doesn't want her to
have the baby she goes ahead I think at
that point when you have that discussion
and he decides then I think you should
you'll know how that's then gonna go so
then it's your choice if you want to
make that choice and have the baby then
I don't know I think it's on you
personally what do you guys think I
would say no absolutely not to to give
them an ex like from a selfish point of
view yeah oh man we get to sign off I'm
out of here but from economical point of
view that's probably the worst thing we
can do is allow men to negate their
responsibility to that child and let
them sign off and have an easy pass out
because I think a lot of I don't want to
generalize but I'm assuming a lot of
women are saying it's fine I can do it
myself but it's not about you it's about
what's best for the kid and the kid
needs his father so do you think do you
think abortion should be illegal then
like if we're gonna make it equal no I
don't know the question but it should be
legal so then why do you think legally
women should get a choice whether or not
they want to be mothers but men
shouldn't have a white man shouldn't
have a choice whether or not they want
to be fathers if I'm raising a son and I
tell them a girl gets pregnant it's 100
your fault I've been with way too many
women I've never got a girl pregnant so
there's no excuse a guy can say no I'm
talking about from a legal perspective
though I'm not an industry
responsibility so then why don't you say
the same thing to a woman like if you
got pregnant it's your responsibility
yes to both right right but you're
saying one should be legal and one
shouldn't why do you like why the double
standard no wait what double standard so
the double standard where a woman has a
choice of whether or not she wants to be
a mother but a guy doesn't have a choice
of whether or not he wants to be a
father so I said I said he wants to sign
all away his rights you're saying so
they have the option yes I believe that
okay it should exist okay I'm not like
saying I would create a society where
I'm promoting it I don't think it's
healthy I agree I agree I agree with you
I think if you look around how many dumb
people that exist on this planet I think
a lot of these people that get pregnant
should not be having kids that's think
the worst thing you can do for our
economy is allow them to bring another
baby in this lot into this world when
they're already pretty messed up or on
drugs I'm thinking that kid's going to
end up in the foster care my parents are
foster parents so I can just see the
trickle effect for all this stuff so in
that even though I don't like abortion
and stuff like that I just think it it
should absolutely available I personally
think that this whole like feminism has
given women a lot of power and taken
power away from men and then what
happens is a lot of the time women
generally tend to use that power to
their advantage when and where they see
fit so like in these cases like in the
cases of abortion like look my body my
choice my body my choice I get to choose
I get to choose all right cool I'm a dad
I get to choose not to oh you're a
deadbeat dad
it's like
what's that all about like if you can
get to choose not to be a mother why
can't I get to choose not to be a dad I
I don't think you should not be able to
choose to be a dad that's what what do
you think yeah you were gone she agreed
but they didn't answer or he didn't so
that's why I was asking okay so I think
if if you do get a girl pregnant you
still are gonna have to finance it
because if you don't financially who's
going to finance it right the woman has
to take care of the child and raise a
child and she's gonna be spending all
her time raising that kid and she won't
have time to work and then the
government's gonna have to step in where
does that money come from right so it
makes sense that the government wants
you know men to pay child support for
the baby
well it was her choice to have the baby
though it is the guy's choice to get her
pregnant no it wasn't yeah it was I I've
trust me I've slept with so many women
never got a girl pregnant so it was it
was his choice like just like you said
right
um You had sex with a woman and she lied
so yeah yeah it was my choice to not use
a condom and ejaculate I could not use a
condom it wasn't his choice to get her
pregnant he ejaculated in her of course
he did it's his fault so it ends there
so all right so once he ejaculates in
her and he's and she's lied to him it's
still his fault he believed her true
actually true stranger
I get it he shouldn't have believed her
I'm assuming more cautious but with the
like I think the point we're making is
like you're promoting a double standard
because life's full of double standards
though yeah I know what I'm saying only
tend to benefit women so I'm just saying
that I'm not trying to I'm just
basically saying every if I'm having a
son the conversation I'm having with
them it's one million percent your fault
but we're not talking about your son
like you keep bringing up your son what
we're saying as a philosophy no no I'm
talking about legally you've said that
legally I'm saying like legally there's
a double standard why if I get a girl
pregnant like women have the right not
to be mothers men don't have the right
not to be fathers from a legal
perspective she can still put you on
child support right you can get put on
child support even though the child's
not biologically yours indeed and I've
heard stories like that that sucks
you know it's really unfortunate for
those men very yeah they think it's
theirs they're raising it for a couple
years they find out later it's not
theirs and then they're legally
obligated to support that child do you
think a man could do that
um no
that's what I'm trying to say the double
there's a yeah
life's not fair and then you know I
understand we're trying to make it equal
but it's not always going to be equal
and certain sticky situations like these
it's like sorry buddy sorry I didn't say
anything um okay
um should we read the super chats yeah
and then we can get to a second off okay
okay guys um don't forget to subscribe
to our Eclipse channel it's just pearly
clips and pearl daily while you're at it
also like the video that is the most
important metric that YouTube uses to
push out these live streams so make sure
you like the video and subscribe I think
we might hit 350k during this live I
don't I don't know yet
um okay let me read the Super Chat so
young Lex
um send these guys back to Canada please
um
biscillin Neva of course the antifa guy
is laughing about the babies being
aborted and has cringe takes it fits his
ideology Mugen
um Sarah Sarah dropping truth and logic
even though it's not a popular opinion
with this modern half not popular
opinion with the modern gen modern with
the modern half the gender population
men have to work Beyond hard to
successfully bet a woman morally and
naturally it does take two to tango
however if a modern woman gets pregnant
nowadays even with the many forms of
birth control available and engineered
towards them it's on her bossy dude in
the black in the Middle with glasses is
a rude guest he's condescending to
others and thinks he knows it all
hvaragus 207 I agree with dazzy Simpson
sat equals SOS Maurice
antifiak the guy in the middle is a
typical example of the men that get
taken advantage of by women Northwest
Pearl my ex chose to stop taking birth
control two years after we had started
having sex together now we have a
four-year-old and don't talk men protect
birth the sky metric 52 why do they use
women for the plural instead of women
it's driving me insane FYI listen to
Pearl she's the real deal road to road
to 500 okay dozie these guys are all
simps wow this is kind of hard to watch
they can't be saved Chris Brown This is
the most clueless group of guests you've
ever had on guy laughing at abortion
needs to sort out his attitude PS you
don't appreciate bras until they're gone
catsy visililla if you bear the greatest
risk you bear the greater proportion of
the responsibility The Wanderer the
biological imperative results in the
Assurance of paternity the imperative
itself is men being inherently
Territorial and protective also don't
forget the damage to women pair bonding
The Savvy ninja I bought I just bought
Kraft mac and cheese because I love it
Jimmy John brought craft because it's
all he could afford Mary Sue bought
craft because her kids wanted her to why
why does it matter we all bought it
still low-key 21 stealthing is a crime
in the U.S third degree grape a marriage
cause causes divorces would Red Wood red
had give Sarah a criminal compassion the
UK Economist great topic Pearl please
your gas if they prefer a conservative
provider who values Purity or a
left-leaning progressive man for a
husband Maurice and ayini fiac the girl
with the red hair is a typical example
of women trying to tell men what they
think men should be
um Edgar Shepherd body count matters
just like job resumes matters having one
job for 10 years is better than having
10 jobs for in 10 years marriage causes
divorces tall redhead data shows high
body count equals divorce high body
count also shows drama chaos baggage
attention seeking and daddy issues bossy
why do Mom and modern women always tell
men that they shouldn't care about their
body count men will always care about a
woman's past Kayla our cat la vasil and
Neva exception to the rule doesn't
eliminate the rule on average women
establish an emotional connection prior
and or during intimacy hence their
ability to pair bond decreases in
relation to their body count increasing
most in 1938 the 20 of failed marriages
when the female doesn't have any
previous Partners could be because she
wasn't and gave him crabs LOL most in
1938 the biggest concern was when I was
14 year old boy was to make sure you
didn't leave the VHS tape that you're
not supposed to have in the VCR when
your parents come home marriage causes
divorces virgin or not as irrelevant do
not get married in the UK you generally
lose about 70 percent in the UK getting
30 percent is not enough to survive as a
guy mohsin 1938 the reason why girls in
religious schools still lose their
virginity is because they're exposed to
the don't judge me I'm a free woman
feminist jargon
now009 thank you for the Super Chat
sticker I'm going to refresh it really
quick just to make sure I didn't miss
any also guys like the video it's the
most important metric that YouTube uses
to push out the live we should have a
thousand likes in here we have over a
thousand people we should have a
thousand likes we're only at 500 so make
sure you like the video
um
um as cc Blue the most beta panel of man
guy on the couch put your socks on your
feet died two years ago H Vargas 207 a
woman with abort a beta but would keep
an alpha
um Nas thank you for the Super Chat
Alexandra Society should always have
children's best interests as a priority
dc-081 it's conversations like these
that will make artificial rooms the
future and men will circumvent women all
together and women will have no power
big brown are there any masculine men in
England kilton Daniels get simps off the
panel Pearl thpp it's ludicrous and
intellectually dishonest to say men have
more Reproductive Rights than women the
laws are written that way purposely
unless a man can take a woman and make
her get or not get an abortion it's not
equal young lacks send these guys back
to Canada please I worry about that one
okay
that was a very interesting bunch of
super chats
um getting back to the topic when it
comes to virginity
do you think
the church
promote
let me try and rephrase this in church
it is told that to be a virgin is a good
thing however do you think that churches
are generally generally have virgins in
them
nope I don't think you have virgins in
them no
explain what do you mean why I've got
real life proof examples of girls I've
met in church that are not virgins
so these non-virgins in church
do you think that
even the most pure place that women are
supposed to be Church
cannot stop human beings from being
promiscuous
I mean I think humans are promiscuous by
Nature I think that's just what we are I
think it's more socially accepted for
women to have sex now whereas before
it's more frowned upon so it's okay
women have sex it's okay like it's not
uh this big taboo thing anymore
um if we're talking about women still
we're talking about just men and women
yeah men and women yeah to virgins in
general I think humans are humans I
think whether they're part of a church
or not I think maybe it's promoted more
to hold your virginity in a church but I
don't really see that being uh in my
experience where I grew up I didn't
really see that being a factor
you grew up in church bell
what was The Virginity like amongst the
people in church and when you grew up
um
I mean I would say like it was just
delayed because I went to Catholic
school so everything that like
the public school kids were doing it
like 14 15 like we did just like when we
got to college I would say it was kind
of delayed
um the other church I was a part of was
like a Christian church and I would say
the girls there was a couple girls I met
there that like waited till they were
married to have sex but they got married
pretty young so I I don't see girls
being more pure like over a certain age
in church like if they do
if they are like they're married
typically at like 20 21 right like you
don't meet a lot of 25 year old virgins
in church no
um he didn't leave guys he just went to
the bathroom yeah
do you think Church nowadays because
I've been to a few churches
um I don't go to church anymore but
um I would look at the
the outfits in church from some of the
ladies right like do you think that
church promotes
Purity when it comes to like some of the
like things that people do in church or
do you think it's just like a show
conservative pure mindset where we don't
talk about sex because it's taboo and
you shouldn't have sex because you know
you will be judged and you have to you
know preserve yourself and that sort of
thing and I think naturally when people
are told that they can't do something
they kind of get more curious about it
um and I think we can kind of sexualize
anything if we feel like it
um so kind of
you know when you have like an
excessively pure space right it's really
easy to start sexualizing that because
that's kind of the whole
um opposite you know on the same
Spectrum right there's always going to
be a middle ground and you can really
kind of really project that onto it it's
it's easy to distort it like that if
that makes sense
I remember your video Power when you
were saying that um these pastas are
like oh pin pin out these oh oh no okay
I have this theory about church yeah go
on and I will say this isn't my church
because I grew up in Catholics so
Catholic was a little different but I
have this theory that like the the
the pastors are like the Homemakers and
what they do is they say you can be
forgiven for being a hoe because they
want to sleep with all the congregations
that's what they do
so they're like yeah yeah you can get
forgiven and then they're like chatting
to them after and then
yeah so like and then they Market it
because what they'll do is they Market
wholeness because they have the Chastity
speakers come back and they're like yeah
I did this this and this and it's always
the girl that got ran through and then
the husband that married her and who did
it and he was like more pure and then
he's the the girl's like yeah um I got
ran through I did all this stuff but
then I found God and found my husband
and so they're like yeah you can just do
whatever you want and then still find a
husband at the end of it and so I feel
like in a way some Churches Market hodem
when you say ran through are you saying
being slept with with lots likes yeah
like like like you know that's oh yeah
yeah like like I slept with him and him
and him him him so like yeah I just
wanted some clarification on that I
wasn't sure yeah I don't know what
though what would you say is the
specific point someone has ran through
I don't know what the number is yeah no
I'm gonna leave those statistics to you
guys I mean I know I mean I've heard
I've had a lot of women in college have
trains running them that's it that's
that's I would say that's the definition
of being ran through it's like more than
like two sexual partners in a night
too sexual maybe two or three I don't
know four
yeah
okay and so does that apply to a male as
well no no no absolutely not no it's
just it's just strictly
towards a female yeah well because men
and women are different it's hard for
men to get sex it's easy for women to
get sex okay all right sweet I'm just
yeah still just clarifying do you think
men can be hoes nope
why explain for a man to sleep with a
lot of women he has to be inherently
attractive or have value he can't just
run around sleeping with him it doesn't
work like that
but if he has is attracted and has value
and runs around sleeping with a lot of
women could he be a hoe no why because
again right attraction is a very
subjective term and women don't
typically look at a man's physical
appearance to determine traction they
typically look at behavior and like
communication style fine but if he
sleeps
if a man sleeps with a lot of women
regardless of who he is you know how
attractive is value whatever if he's
sleeping with another woman wouldn't he
be a hoe you're applying the exact same
parameters but withdrawing well he can't
a man can't get pregnant right and so
there's no negative consequence to him
sleeping a lot of women
I mean STDs but also why is that
notification here is is that a woman who
sleeps with a lot of men right that's
that's because because that's easy to do
so it's like it's easy for a woman to
sleep with a lot of guys go outside and
say does anyone want to have sex with me
you can get it done if a dude does that
they look at him like he's nuts
you know what changed my like
perspective on this is I went to a
pickup artist boot camp once this is the
wildest thing I've ever seen like these
guys paid thousands of dollars to learn
how to get laid Yeah thousands of
dollars and literally like went through
coaching like trying to figure out how
to build attraction with a girl like all
this stuff and I'm just like all I all I
have to do is exist so if you bring that
back too you have a vagina but if we
bring that back to what we're talking
about in terms of virginity when we were
younger in terms of like girls weren't
really thinking about it that much and
kind of saw it as this Victory right
isn't that what we're taught but that's
what's pushed on to us that men losing
their virginity and sleeping with lots
of women is like this you know like high
achievement so they pay lots of money
because if you get laid a lot then
you're seen as you know successful right
yeah I would say it is a high
achievement because historically most
men didn't even reproduce only 40 of men
reproduce historically where 80 of women
did and even up 8 000 years ago 17 women
reproduced for every one man and so it's
it's like that's an achievement most men
don't even get to reproduce and I know
like now you know you take away the
reproduction because we have birth
control but you don't get rid of biology
so are we reducing it to reproduction
then so when that was the initial yeah
we've definitely developed as a society
right past that point where it's not
just about reproduction but I'm saying
like you can't get rid of the way people
feel
in terms of like men are naturally
predisposition to be repulsed by a girl
that sleeps around and so I'm just like
the same way you typically women like
men that are taller than us and men
don't come to us and say oh you
shouldn't like men taller than us like
no so I would say again that that would
like there's some angry little men out
there
I
in terms of that like evolving over time
right biologically evolving over time
I'd say that there's other attitudes
that have also evolved over time kind of
and that are probably taking up more
space now maybe haven't got to the same
point as that same mindset but I do
think we can get to a point where that
can shift right especially because it's
evolved it's a Minds that's evolved
based on what we've been taught we can
be taught different things and change
that gradually but we have to be open to
that so I I agree with you I do think
it's evolved over time where like
typically before as I said like I would
say men are more forgiving with body
count than they used to be so I would
agree with you that it has evolved but
is it better
like are the outcomes better nowadays is
that any space that kind of promotes
like I said acceptance and understanding
of why we behave in certain ways and why
we drift towards certain things and and
understanding how it can harm because I
feel like that kind of mindset of like
um in terms of you know if you slept a
lot of people as like woman as a man
you're successful is is essentially
harmful
um because it places a lot of that
emphasis on on that um
but the thing is it's true and I just
think like you can live in delusion it's
true right now and I would agree with
that yes 100 I would say that that is if
we talk about like the general that is
kind of the general mindset at the
moment I would agree but does that mean
it's the best mindset right and and who
are you to determine what's the best
mindset yeah because I'm trying to
understand that he you said it's harmful
harmful to who like so so in terms of
like situations like grape right men who
or like in cells right who who don't
maybe have that same achievement right
they they kind of resort to quite
violent means in order to reach that
same level success or they feel kind of
like you know put out because they don't
get to be able to do it and that's why
in cell culture kind of develops because
they think like a certain group of men
only gets all the women because you know
they're this high level and then and
then often they turn violent right and
it can be a very destructive view when
you place all the emphasis on that like
Macho not Macho which are probably not
the right word to say there
um that like hyper masculine focus on on
sexuality and seeing it as something to
achieve right when we do that and then
men don't and then they don't feel
masculine anymore and they feel
emasculated by it and that can turn very
violent so it can be dangerous for
society and I'm not saying this is me
you know saying oh this is I'm saying
it's a point to consider it's a thing to
talk about when we're considering what's
best forever you're actually somewhat
correct it is dangerous for society what
like the more um
like the when there's a large group of
men that aren't getting laid basically
that is dangerous versus you know what
happens when men don't get laid but it's
because the emphasis is on the fact you
know and that's where we've put so it
becomes more aggressive
no males yeah exactly they become more
aggressive when they don't but I think
that's because of the emphasis that we
put on being late and essentially from
biology survival reproduction yeah it's
not an emphasis it's a biological thing
but it's it's we are taught that we are
taught that through biology that is
something that is evolved based on what
we've been taught and through a need for
survival right to reproduce to be able
to you know reproduce your bloodline in
lineage and that sort of thing it's a
survival
you don't know what it is there are
other ways to release you don't have to
release
you're a woman I'm a man men need to
release their testosterone they need to
have testosterone hang on hang on they
need to find a way in which they need to
release how do you release how do you
release but by shagging some shagging
some birds is that how you release is
that is that your release is that sorry
you just said you just said wait wait
yeah I hate you but what I'm saying to
you is men are biologically wired a
certain way okay are you a biologist
men are biologically wired a certain way
okay okay so so what happens in society
is that when men are not getting
sexual when men are not sexually uh most
of what I'm looking for gratified
gratified gratified yes that's the word
but men are not sexually gratified they
get more aggressive do they so okay
sorry sorry when they are more sexy
gratified they're less violent
okay that is the biggest logical fallacy
I've ever heard in mind it's not a
logical fallacy it is it's true
thank you I'd have to agree you're right
okay so so we've got three minutes
saying it's true so you explain why it's
a logical fallacy so you're saying that
if I don't get laid I'm gonna hit
someone I said you explain why it's a
logical fallacy well you said you've
never had trouble talking to women so
you probably wouldn't know what that's
like right like you said earlier in the
show you've never had trouble talking to
women you're good with the ladies yeah
so you guys should really ask Justin
about this yeah you should really asked
Justin about this he has a lot of study
in history and like knowledge on the go
and Justin well so I mean it's
evolutionary psychology but more person
than that like I mean if a man
masturbates he can get it early so you
won't feel as aggressive right but if I
mean I don't know if you guys ever heard
of nofap I'm a huge advocate for the no
fat movement and I'm like seven years
into it right and I know if I don't have
sex for like I don't know a week or two
I start feeling extremely aggressive
right and I think it's very common for
for men to feel that way because when
you abstain from sex your testosterone
is increasing you need to have that
release and if you don't believe me go
try it go stop jerking off stop having
sex for two weeks three weeks and see
how you feel but would you not agree
with those other ways to release other
than just sexual you're a woman
yeah no I've realized that I'm talking
to men thank you but I I can enter into
the conversation yeah I don't think
about it right and I'm saying are there
not other ways for you to release not
just sex or through exercise right
through physical engagement and healthy
in in a controlled environment right
it's not the same as busting a nut
fair enough thank you just thank you for
being so like so Justin you're gonna be
so honest you're like you're you're club
promoter YouTuber yep yes yes so like
your your work Outlet is
having conversations like this yeah and
busting a nut yeah yeah sure yeah sweet
so how how do you how do you manage your
aggression you say you're seven years
into this nofap how do you manage your
question when you feel it coming up fair
enough
what if you can't have sex that's when
it's been aggressive yeah that's that's
those are the incels is what we're
talking about that's that's what do you
do you get gravy but what yeah what do
you what what do you do as somebody
who's actually because I don't know wet
dreams well okay fair but there is you
you do manage your aggression that means
you're not going around graping people
or hitting people or stuff why do we
have to go to the extreme but I'm just
wondering how far I've never heard of
anything you're actually someone you're
you're somewhat correct like that does
happen historically like when um there
are large groups of men that aren't
getting laid like they do get angry and
violent like yeah right but this guy
seems to be like if it just gets laid
yeah he's chilling yeah
I mean I don't want to say luckily but
like corn is a thing yeah yeah yeah
so that's that's what I would guess I I
personally believe the reason why um no
uh no uh what's it called only fans okay
it became so popular during the lockdown
it's because they're a load of men
that weren't getting late and so they
had to find a way in which to release
they had to I'm sure porn uh corn sorry
um consumption went through the roof
during lockdown there's also another
factor I think we're missing out on is
that a lot of these men that have are
virgins and through their adulthood and
haven't experienced that it's not just
the sex they're not even getting to
experience what it's like to have female
energy or right or infection from a
woman they don't even get to experience
that and I don't think people can fathom
the idea of how lonely of a life these
men leave uh live like absolutely lonely
just depressed people and you know it's
like I've met some of uh Justin students
and some of them are you know he's a
pickup coach he's a dating coach I need
to I'm just I need to like look you up
Justin by going and some of the students
you know they're virgins and I'm meeting
them and I'm like I can't even think
because sometimes to me when I hang out
with girls it's not just sex like I say
you just want to be around the female
energy like if it's just sex you can get
a prostitute and have just sex it's
empty right but to even have a female's
attention affection you know towards you
it's it's fulfilling I think as a man
but for a guy that doesn't even have
that it's like they live in a whole
other world that I don't think most
people understand Justin if I can ask
you candidly sure do you have it into
the microphone please yes sorry I keep
not it's okay it's not normally my jam
no I get you um how do you have any
closed female friends definitely like
good friends like people that you yeah
you completely open up yes it is yes
sweet cool
um no just I just because I like I like
I work with I like I work with a lot of
a lot of men who don't have female
friends and their female friends are
acquaintances it's uh it's their friends
it's their friends
girlfriends it's that's and that's it
and yes I'm not I'm not trying to like
frame you yeah I just I was just oh yeah
so I kind of I got a bit lost there but
and imagine as a club promoter you have
to have a lot of female friends yeah so
uh typically yeah I bring out 300 girls
a weekend to party with me and I'm not
sleeping all the girls but uh a lot of
them know all of them but um you know
most of them are just friends of mine
and but it's it's cool because it gives
me constant access to meeting you women
right
like it is what it is like men need to
release like I don't know I would I
don't know why that's such a hard thing
to conclude no no no and I would agree
I would say that that is you know a
biological factor that we can't really
account for but I think also in terms of
like uh when you talk about loneliness
and when you talk about them not having
really that nurturing energy to be
around I think that's also something to
focus on as well is the reason they
resort to aggression or violent
tendencies is largely because they
probably don't have a nurturing side or
that feminine energy that is nurturing
right
um which is kind of like you know
encouraging them to you know be more
um soft I want to say that's kind of
like the feminine influence it softens
things right
um and if you don't have that around
then you're more likely to resort to
violent tendencies and I don't
necessarily think that sex is the only
way to be able to deal with aggression
soft men don't gain respect I disagree
with that I just so what do you mean by
Stockman what do you mean by Soft men
don't get me women don't respect soft
men Society doesn't respect software
what do you mean by software
feminine men do not gain respect again
later men do not gain respect man what
do you mean by that okay so men that are
that are forthright within within their
views men that are Stern men that are
logical men that are authoritative gain
respect of course right but okay
but there's an emotional intelligence
required in there as well which I think
would still count as you know logical
minded It's just emotional intelligence
I would say is more of a feminine aspect
that we all have within us right we all
have emotions we all have a feeling Side
and being able to understand that is
integral to be able to managing yourself
managing your impulses like your
aggression and right you can understand
why you feel aggression you're more able
to manage it and if you're not how to do
that then what are you supposed to do
well I think I think you're looking at
that from a woman's point of view okay
and so and so I'm saying like that's not
how men are respected in society
typically but do you think that's a
byproductive right I I think it's just
like you can't undo biology and it just
is what it is and I just and I I just
think we should stop trying to change
the way people are but you cannot do
biology there's epigenetics right your
DNA is constantly shifting and changing
based on the environments you're in
right you constantly respond to your
environment right your brain can
constantly change it's constantly like a
neuroplasticity right you can change
your biology right and it's about what
we're fed you say Society is you know
that's the way it's set up yes I agree
but I think there's a better Society
where we can teach but but I just think
who are you to say like how we should be
and that's that's what I'm saying like
I'm not like you're trying to do I'm
saying like I'm saying we've gotten to
this point yeah through like thousands
of years of evolution and like societies
being built and now we're saying f it
and let's change it completely I'm not
saying we haven't made Mass developments
and that sort of thing but I think you
know the there's a better way I'm not
saying that my you know word of gospel
anything that that I think is worth
talking about though when we live in a
society where a lot of people are
struggling a lot of people are
struggling to survive right and and it's
not the best Society for everyone and if
we truly want to incorporate everyone's
best like interest into society and make
sure that everyone is understood and
acceptable in love you know what we
should do we should bring back virgin
girls because that would give the best
best outcomes because like the best
outcomes is a family societies are built
off of families
is it good for society and people in
general to have baby mamas left and
right is that good is that good for a
family is that a healthy situation for a
kid to grow up in if you have people who
aren't understanding who aren't
compassionate and who aren't able
provide love then no I would say it's
not a good Society but I think our
society do you think in general just in
general
would you say in general it's good for a
kid to be raised by a single mother in
general just yes or no I would say that
yesterday no no I know I know but I need
I just need I think it can be I think it
can be it just depends on the community
that's around them okay okay it really
doesn't it doesn't even even though that
puts a kid even though even though that
puts a kid at every statistical
disadvantage they're more likely to run
away from home they're more likely to
drop out of school because we live in a
system that doesn't support single
mothers doesn't support
it okay okay how do you not support
single mothers when if you get pregnant
you can have an abortion and you get
free housing if you get pregnant I think
if you're a single mother and you get
government benefits those are basic
human rights that doesn't happen to men
they're just homeless
I think we all deserve compassion and we
deserve to live in a society where
everyone has their basic human rights
for it who pays for it like that's a
conversation we need to start having
it's a conversation we genuinely need to
start having if we want everyone to live
at a certain standard and actually be
able to live and then how do we how do
we like why do I have to pay for someone
who made poor decisions like if you
chose to be a single mother I didn't
choose to do that I I damn well could be
pregnant right now like why do I have to
pay for someone else's bad decision you
made that decision and like oftentimes
we try to take accountability off of
women and we stop them from facing the
consequences of your decisions like that
was a decision you made no and and I
agree I think everyone should have
accountability but that we also can't
place blame on people but that comes
with accountability it's blame
but when when you place the blame right
wouldn't working out how we could make a
better system like accountability is
saying that was my fault and taking
blame so like even earlier when they're
being accountable they're saying yeah
I'm taking the blame so so collectively
educating people to not make those
decisions right to make decisions no I
think women are educated we just choose
not to I mean you you know what you're
doing when you have sex you know when
you're ovulating you you know if you're
if you're on birth control or not on
birth girl you know all of these things
and you make a choice I would I would
say the intelligent the the way we are
educated maybe is kind of the wrong
Focus because we're not educating around
emotional you know emotional stability
we choose men who leave or we choose men
who aren't going to stand up because
like you said last time that we we
choose to ignore red flags right and I
think there's a lot of factors that go
into that right and we aren't really
taught you know about how our
relationships with our parents or how
our you know primary relationships
really govern the relationships that we
choose right and so a lot of us go
through that kind of space not being
aware of what we're choosing and I'm not
saying that removes accountability I say
you have to be accountable but if we can
create a system that teaches people
about these Dynamics we can stop that
from happening I think women we just
don't care I mean I I have sat down with
friends and said yo
here's red flag number one here's red
flag number two I here's a PowerPoint on
why this isn't gonna work and and women
we don't care because when we when we
like a guy we just See No Evil Hear No
Evil right and and if you end up in a
bad situation and you get pregnant by
that guy like it doesn't matter women
don't care as a matter of fact last time
when you were on the show I read a bunch
of Statistics as to when it comes to
single mothers right but then I hang on
I read a bunch of Statistics as to why
single uh children born of single
mothers are statistically a disadvantage
when it comes to homelessness when it
comes to prison when it comes to
adoption when it comes to all of these
things and still even with all the
statistics people find a way in which to
justify a reason to become a single
mother right and it's like
when you speak I'm not saying that you
know what you're saying isn't valid I'm
saying regardless after you speak
statistics are still there
they are still there but like I said
last time I would say there are other
factors that go into that there's
factors of the system right people
living in poverty people living in
circumstances that they aren't able to
properly give support to a child right
and I'm not saying that Society has to
step up and necessarily support that I
think we should live in a more
Collective and collaborative Society
where everyone puts in the same amount
of effort I think I should have five
million dollars in my bank account but I
don't I don't know that's relevant to
what I was saying for fair enough I hope
it happens I think you think you think
but the reality is different yeah so the
reality is different but how can we
shift the reality if we don't think if
we don't think ahead to the way we can
do things better the way we can support
people better right how can we change
the world we're in to to help people
live if we don't think about that if we
don't have this I would say by taking
accountability for your decisions and
saying don't sleep around with men you
don't want to be fathers with I like and
I'm saying I'm saying like take
accountability for the lot your lot in
life hey if you get pregnant and you're
a single mom no one's bailing you out
because that's a poor decision yeah like
I and I think that would remove that
would like even we had um this grandma
on here Auntie Auntie Jenny and she was
saying like people in her day would get
pregnant because they wanted to move out
of their house and the government got
them a house in my day yeah in my day
women would get pregnant just so they
can get flat just so they can get an
apartment and yeah because because UK
government would give you an apartment
if you're a single mother and I think
you have a really positive like world
view where you think maybe people won't
take advantage of that but they do no
and I'm I'm aware of that and I I do
know that I have a very you know I do I
I'm aware of that Within Myself it's not
Whimsical I'm trying I'm working on
grounding it which is why I enjoy being
in spaces like this because it helps
pull me out of that but I don't think
it's impossible to be able to build a
world like that and I do agree that
people will take advantage of it right
but it's about getting to a point where
they don't have to take advantage of it
where we can educate people about
accountability and making better choices
right but we have to also bring
compassion and understanding before we
do that understand why people in these
situations so you can shift it so what
what happened when you educate people
and they don't care so I'll give you
I'll give you okay I'll give you an
example so I I have a relative okay I'm
not gonna
sometimes my family's watching these
things
now sometimes I'd be a little too
specific in my stories and I hear back
uh I have a relative and she is someone
who will probably be homeless and on the
street
um and the reason is because she is a
single mom and the reason is because she
made poor decisions where she was an
alcoholic for years and stole from every
every relative until everyone was sick
of taking care of her yeah and so it's
like why does she need to get bailed out
because she makes it makes poor
decisions she robbed all of us and and I
agree right again accountability is what
led to those decisions I don't know her
her brother trauma that's what I mean
and that's what I'm saying you have to
understand this and I'm not saying it's
not an excuse right they still take
accountability for that people who have
mental health episodes you're awful to
people still to take accountability for
that but if you can understand the root
of it you can begin to shift you can
understand the root and still take
accountability and by dealing with the
consequences of having no one bail you
out like my dad grew up in the same home
he grew up to be a multi-millionaire
with 10 kids and a beautiful family and
so it's like same house you like and
that's what I'm saying you don't have an
excuse like she doesn't have an excuse
she she had the yeah I have a very like
similar family situation friendly enough
it's actually sorry
family situation where my dad was
someone who built himself out of that
situation he made better choices and he
provided him his life I have because he
made a decision to get out and you the
rest of his family didn't really do that
and I've seen that right and I
understand that but I still think they
deserve compassion for what they've had
to struggle with right some people are
predisposed to making bad choices and
but just based on you know I don't know
I guess
but there's a difference between there's
a difference between there's a
difference between compassion I can say
like I understand but there's I don't
think it's compassionate or kind to bail
someone out of a bad decision and allow
them to keep doing it like in this in
this situation I think that relative
would have stopped if people stopped
bailing her out and while and initially
it seems kind and compassionate it
allowed her to use everyone for years
and if someone cut her off from the
beginning she may have had a better
outcome
I want to kind of go back to what I the
initial question I asked about men being
holes and um Justin Justin yep you were
saying that men can't be hoes right
um
do as a woman
do you understand why a man can't be a
hoe
yeah based on the conversation that
we've had and the way that you look at
it yes but I would say that I I look at
it a bit differently but because I don't
apply that same like could you explain
why men can't be no I I understood your
explanation I get it right it's success
because you have to work so hard to
sleep with so many women so therefore
you're not a hoe because the effort you
have to put in I get it right for me
success with how many people do you also
get that women generally want men with
sexual experience
I think it depends on the person to be
honest
um I think personally yeah I prefer
someone with sexual experience probably
but I also would be with someone without
sexual experience if we connect it it
just kind of depends on in Europe the
vibe is you know do you think that women
want a man with sexual experience or no
sexual experience yeah
but I mean it's not like a trick
question it's yeah it's the honest
question yeah but I do think it's
possible to also be with someone who
doesn't have sexual experience just
because that's my preferred because
that's what I think I mean a lot of
things a lot of times like like where
does this even come up in the like do
you go oh hey I'm I've met this girl I'm
gonna maybe sleep with them oh how much
like oh they're gonna go oh how many how
many girls have you slept with oh what's
the transaction no I think it's
conversation everybody sleep with like I
actually ask every single almost every
single girl I meet and hang out I'm just
out of curiosity do you put a lot of
weight on that so if a woman has left
with a lot of like men do you say okay
I'm not gonna sleep with you just
because no I personally I love women who
in general uh and I I definitely like
hoes but I won't date them why because
uh I don't want a woman I'm gonna be
emotionally committed to to have all
this emotional baggage from a past
relationship so it doesn't necessarily
have this is kind of what I was trying
to say before it doesn't have to equate
to emotional baggage if if a person
chooses to acknowledge it and take
accountability for the fact that they
accept a lot of people right you can
step out and what people can change
would you say in general it does
in in I think General like like a girl a
girl like we had we had Linda on the
show yeah yeah bro this girl is so cute
and innocent she she she's 20 and a
virgin yeah like she's the cutest sweet
like she was on the last show what's her
Instagram first
and and like like you could tell she had
no baggage no trauma like every like
like joke anyone would say like it would
just go over her head because she was so
innocent you just don't get that with
girls that have slept around a lot like
you can you can even if you don't know
their body count like you can kind of
just tell because they're more damaged
people can have damage without having
slept around you can have emotional
baggage without it being you can you're
right you're correct you can but I'm
saying in general yeah would you say
that the virgins tend to have less
baggage than the people that did only
fans say they probably have other
baggage that's what I mean maybe less
sexual
reactions but you need to learn to
articulate them like this is I love it
it just explodes my [ __ ] mind because
this is all like I would not even
consider any one of these things a
prerequisite or a parameter for like
someone that I would potentially enter
into a relationship or have intimacy
with or like it just it would it's
completely [ __ ] foreign to me excuse
my language
like like it just it's just completely
foreign to me I would not I like I don't
understand it I've been in polyamorous
relationships I've been like I I I I
just I just like yeah
I just don't understand it it just like
I would never even be like oh hey hey
we're like hanging out for the first
time how many people have you slept with
like I just wouldn't even wouldn't even
come into my brain how often are you
meeting new dating partners
like fail fairly frequently so you're
not communicating with them what's that
you're not like communicating with them
but yeah of course I am okay I I think
the point is more that like body count
isn't really a part of when you say
relationships are you saying that you're
in a relationship where the woman that
you're with can sleep with other men
yeah I've been in open relationships
plenty that's I was actually my question
yeah I just want to clarify yeah yeah
yeah I'll gladly clarify so the woman
that you're with is actually cool with
sleeping with other men well like you're
cool with it well like it's like it's
not particularly in this no not in this
moment but you've been in there yeah
many times many times but it's also man
that I've been out of sleep with other
people so do you know a cuckold is I
know exactly yeah that's what that would
be yeah so you've been a cuckold no no
that's nothing it's completely
consensual and it's completely with
boundaries in place do you have any
preference is out of curiosity in terms
of what uh whether you guys have an open
relationship or just a committed
relationship
um I normally prefer an open
relationship so you prefer her being
able to sleep with other guys and maybe
she got to sleep with other people but
no judgment on it I'm just curious like
you it doesn't matter to you she comes
home she got railed by three different
dudes and then she comes back says baby
I love you and I'm just like but I think
he kisses you and all that if that's her
choice then and I think I think as well
with that it kind of allows for sorry
yes my masculinity isn't that fragile I
know I'm quiet I'm like I don't I don't
know how
much masculinity you have after a woman
is you're allowing your woman to get
penises from somewhere else so how do
you define masculinity
um men are territorial creatures are
they yeah they are okay and um if my
woman yes your woman yeah yeah your
possession our possession I'm a
territory individual yeah so you're you
claim your woman your owner if the woman
that I have stated that this is mine is
gonna tell me that she's gonna go and
get a penis from somewhere else and she
can just go there yes you know what I
mean you're not gonna come back but you
can go and I'm saying maybe maybe I
would say that the majority of men I
think that I would be
okay in saying the majority of men would
not want their woman being [ __ ] down
by somebody else maybe that's the case
of your own masculinity being a little
bit fragile then if you're not it's
biology like we said no it's not biology
you keep using that term but I just
think men don't like wiping These Hoes
come on it's okay to sleep with them
just don't hate them I said why like but
like but like like it's like okay
because you are your habit so I wouldn't
want to date a guy that's cheated on
every single girlfriend that he's ever
had and and so I can understand why a
guy wouldn't want to date a girl that's
been sleeping around for 10 years
because it's going to be hard to one day
stop and I honestly feel the same way a
little bit about guys because if a
dude's been sleeping around forever what
are the odds I'm gonna get him to settle
down right and so like I can understand
where guys are coming from you just guys
put some really [ __ ] weird parameters
I'm just saying the woman that you're
letting go out and sleep with other men
she's not yours she's not your woman of
course she's not mine I don't own
anything
no no she's she's her own autonomous
individual person
like she's not my possession you seem to
be putting a lot of ownership onto your
onto your girlfriend you seem to be
acting like you should have a a a a a
collar around her neck and she's your
pet I mean yeah
yeah I'm not even I'm not here for
[ __ ] King Shame and I don't get me
don't get me wrong don't get me wrong
but you're putting a lot of you're
putting a lot of oh she is mine whereas
I'm saying No this person that I'm with
is
if I was to get married to a guy I would
feel like I'm his we'll see genuinely
like yeah I've done Nintendo never
getting married I think I think it's a I
think I think the idea of marriage is
quite strange to be honest so like and I
and I get that it's not for everyone but
I I like I don't really mind the idea of
like belonging to a guy I actually kind
of like it of course yeah of course and
that's your own projarative isn't it but
like but but do you want a guy
specifically saying that they control
you and that you're I mean I think I
think there are levels but I would like
I would like a guy that could lead me
and make decisions for us and I would
really like to add that I could trust to
make decisions with your consent as well
though with with your consent on top of
that well yeah that's submission not
yeah not to just force there well I
don't I think all of I think all of the
guys are like they want a guy that or
girl not a guy a girl that wants to
follow them
it's not like they wanna they want a
girl that doesn't want to be there
so so like I'm saying like if if I was
with a guy and he wanted to have an open
relationship on both ends I would I
would be concerned I would think like
what because I would I would trust your
judgment because I just think that's bad
judgment on a guy's part no offense like
yeah
do you think a woman actually respects
you if she's taking penis from somebody
else
like if she's taking a penis from
elsewhere and she's coming do you think
she actually respects you can we ask the
girl maybe I'm actually curious to get
your take on this if you're dating a guy
let's just say words
baby I love you you're everything I ever
wanted in a girl you're perfect your
body your smiled the way you treat me
everything about you is perfect but if
you want to go out and [ __ ] other guys
I'm totally cool with it how would you
take that but this this is and
interesting question I'm actually okay
with with your belief system it's like
teach their own it's not the norm yeah
so it's probably weird to hear but if
you know teach their own
everyone can have their own beliefs
about oh so we talk about me personally
yeah
I mean it's a bit cuckoo yeah
you can just you can describe to
whatever yeah I'm curious what you're
gonna say go ahead uh it's an
interesting question to ask me right now
um I
I've always really valued the idea of
monogamy
um and when I was like 19 I fell in love
with someone
uh and it was not a healthy relationship
was pretty toxic but I really love the
idea that we were each other's persons
so I really believe in that I believe
that I have a person out there who I'm
going to be a team with right and I
believe in the masculine and The
Feminine Dynamic right I do believe in
that
um I've considered the idea of polyamory
before right
um just based on the fact that when I
met this person I thought I would never
connect anyone as deeply as I could
connect to him right right and that was
more spiritually emotionally that sort
of thing and since then I've met a lot
of people that I've connected
emotionally and spiritually to and it's
not always been sexual sometimes that's
just friendships and that sort of thing
but I realized that the depth of
connection I can have with people isn't
really limited to one person I still
have an idea that I believe I have my
person
um but I I think I could entertain the
idea of an open relationship
um would you prefer it
this is where I'm at right now I
actually don't know you don't know I
don't know it's still something I'm
trying to figure out because I do like I
said I I value the idea of um like I
want a family I want to have you know I
want to be a mom I want to have a kid I
want to have a very strong family
Dynamic that's kind of something I see
for myself um
um and I don't know if an open
relationship would necessarily be
conducive to that based based on what
Society kind of says right but I also
believe that a child can be raised in a
happy environment regardless of the
parameters of the relationship as long
as they're loved forget what society
says I think if you meet a man yeah
right and he loves you and you love him
he's going to not generally generally
he's not going to want to let you you're
not going to want to loan your vagina
out yeah and this is why I don't know if
I'm polarized because because I don't
like the idea of someone I'm with
sleeping with other people I'd want to
be that you know we choose each other
right and we commit to each other and
then we would grow and build whatever
from there
um I I kind of like that this is I don't
know if it doesn't get in TMI but I like
the idea of bringing someone else into
the relationship I'm
can the mother of your child alone her
vagina at somebody
I don't have any children but I would
predict no for me guys absolutely not no
chance
he may learn your vagina vagina out it's
not
transaction it may is what if she gets
pregnant
what if she gets pregnant individual
you are a unique individual yeah I know
I [ __ ] I love it it's great by the
way I'm not gonna lie it's great TV but
I'm just saying like I would you be okay
with the mother of your child
in a polyamorous relationship with you
yes what if she gets pregnant with
another man's child yeah that's a good
question
if she has consented like then like
would you raise the child well I I I I
was raised by a stepfather so you would
raise the child yes I was I I was like
my the the the the man the the male that
raised me my Alpha it was not my
biological father
Society does need you know men to raise
the women's kids in certain
circumstances and and this is this so
one I saw something like it but I think
it was a post or something about a
lawyer who was like a divorce lawyer and
he was saying to this couple that you
know what if my kids have to grow up
with you know two sets of parents and
they said well a kid can never have
enough people to love them right there's
always more people that can love a child
and help them grow right kids are raised
by a village right and the more people I
love them but they do need a biology the
problem is not necessarily not
necessarily they need a strong masculine
figure yes and that can manifest it I
will say that one problem is that like
the I can't remember the stat off the
top of my head I'd look it up but my
laptop died they took it
but it's like the when somebody is a
single parent the most likely person
that is going to sexually abuse them as
someone they bring into the house in a
relationship and so you're putting your
kid at risk and I know everyone thinks I
know everyone thinks like oh it wouldn't
happen if me like I would vet them
better but you just never know everybody
and that's so then so then I would bring
it back to saying that's probably the
exception and that's the biggest reason
in terms of that context because I and I
think if we go back to like properly
vetting someone and probably making
proper choices right you have to
consider the kids right and that's
that's that's you know if you do that
then you're probably not taking an
answer I agree with you I do think it's
the exception not the rule I don't think
that every single step parent is abusing
the child but the the point the but the
point is you're still putting that kid
at risk for abuse you're putting them at
risk they're more likely to run away
from home they're more likely to
um to be on the streets yeah to be on
drug like it's like every every city
mental health issues every statistical
advantage that you could put a kid at
you're putting them at in a single
parent home right and to be in jail
as much as you like but you're still
just throwing random numbers that don't
actually have anything okay okay I can't
even tell you like just anecdotally and
like so just from talking to people day
to day like I I have nine siblings same
two parents we've adopted three and like
when I talk to people that come from
single parent homes about like my
family's Traditions every year like I've
never seen like such like like they want
that so bad it's really sad like they've
never experienced like no I'm sorry
sorry I'm laughing at something else
um no it's it's sad though like they've
never experienced like Christmas with
both parents together like and then all
the traditions we do like we do pictures
with Santa every year we do like an
Easter egg hunt like like family's
really big and I I just see like the
loss that's someone's out when they
didn't get to grow up with two parents
and I just wouldn't wish that upon
anyone but I think I think again that
comes down to two parents yes but also
having adults that love you right and
adults that are a team that can raise
you right because that's a big family
and you have Traditions but you can have
traditions in lots of different family
Dynamics right and the polyamorous room
right where the team comes together to
raise a kid you can still build
Traditions well it's just a bit of a
different Dynamic but I think I think
it's better like we kind of did have a a
team raise us because like we had we had
help and we also had like relatives that
stepped in my grandma's like I could
name you a long list of people that
helped and stepped in but I think it's
better when it's like in the family and
it's all what's the difference between a
community that you build in a community
that's biological like what's I would
say I would say it's it's like more
vetted and so like you're happy because
you're going around people that have
known each other for years for a year
like and and more vetted that like
because family members are um no but
family members are they they can be that
person who sexually abuses you know it
is possible for that to happen right
that's not not gonna happen you're
correct but I would say that it's easier
to like I put it
like everyone knows who the weird uncle
is everyone everyone knows exactly
is in the family and you keep your kids
away from the weird uncle and I'm not
saying it doesn't happen but I
just anecdotally would guess that it
happens at a much lower rate when it's
family than when it's random people that
you've met I don't know if you'd be able
to can I just say because I want to go
back to what something that you said
because I said that children need two
biological parents and you said that
they don't yeah right
how do you reconcile that a child who
was born of two people
doesn't need those two people
how do you reconcile like how how do you
say they don't need that if that if
that's how they came into the world
so so my entire existence I was raised
by someone who wasn't my biological
parent and he's my father and he's was
your mother there your biological mother
was my biological mother was there yes
and I was raised by my stepfather who
wasn't my biological father and he had
I've had four sisters two were from a
relationship prior to him being with my
mother and then he had two sisters he
had two daughters with my mother and he
was do you know do you know your
biological father at all you do yes I do
so you don't have a relationship with
him I don't have a massive relationship
with him but I've had I've like I've had
a a like we're not I don't dislike him I
don't like as a child if we go back to
your childhood yes did you want to know
who your father was I knew him
I did know him okay yeah like okay but
you were you were you were lucky you had
someone step in you did have two parents
in the home yeah and but I'm saying not
every kid is that lucky yeah but like
and you had a good and you had a good
step father of course but of course but
that wasn't that wasn't the argument
that you always put to me but you
already knew him so imagine you didn't
know him you don't think that children
want to know their biological parents
well so like until I was old enough to
be able to actually like with my human
brain Quantified that he would like what
the difference was between my stepdad
and my real dad I didn't I didn't know
did I and then I was I was I was
introduced to that and I was explaining
the Dynamics of that of that situation
and I was able to to to comprehend all
that and I've grown up pretty damn fine
as far as uh yeah I might be I might be
confusing to to you definitely confusing
to me yeah yeah yeah but yeah I I know
I'm not I'm not normally down with the
podcast button no I hate you I hate you
but it's good to like you know engage
but
but like the point is you were lucky you
had a good step dad yeah but that's not
every kid right of course but but but
but but what like but like what who has
a better incentive that a kid turns out
good than both of the biological parents
who is more incentive to make sure that
kid turns out okay well my biological
dad wanted to have me aborted so
that happens yeah yeah did he tell you
that
yes he told you that he wanted to have
you avoid yes you don't think that I
confronted about it yeah you don't think
that had an effect on your psychological
at all no
no because I'm not a [ __ ] idiot I
like I I'm I'm well aware that sometimes
things happens in life and you you like
circumstances are out of our control and
sometimes I know if like yeah your
biological parent told you that he
didn't want that they didn't want you
here you don't think they had an effect
on your psychology at all nah no lots of
other things about effects on my
psychology but I don't think that did
I don't know your life okay I'm just
gonna say okay yeah no no like yeah I'm
like yeah okay I came here to challenge
these idea no no I hate you okay yeah if
you set a leg it's just like I'm I'm
doing my job I'm doing a jam
do your thing man do you think uh pal um
we're gonna have to wrap up soon yeah so
we might have to read the rest of the
super chats all right don't I'm sorry
you probably got about a thousand yeah
let's see let's see
don't shoot the messenger
um okay KCF sack shout out to King
Richie's in the chat waiting for your
reaction to this cluster F Wizard or
shout out king Richie um wizard ape um
facts as embryos are exposed to
endocrine distributors in the womb men
can be born with shortened distance of
the tank correlation with the men having
discreased testosterone Not all men are
the same
um Al Draco malfo Draco Malfoy is PMSing
um B Jokers I'm the third I'm 35 years
old and I've never met my dad trust me
it sucks as a man
um Bazi I can tell the middle simp loves
Andrew Tate
um Mark Peru Purdue the statistics first
step parents are comparable to single
Parenthood in some cases in some cases
worse it has to be when they're four or
less wizard ape the wall and feminine
urge for monogamy are reproductive urge
feminism will trick you into breaking
your ability to pattern Bond and you'll
instead fall into a loop of failed
relationships
um Mosin 1938 and polygamous situation
chips do you meet the other sexual
partners and do you ask your sexual
partner to get tested regularly 93 times
poligma I don't know
very different that's just what they
wrote um 90 free-toe pay ball dude you
don't see women as your own as your own
because you don't have a plan for the
Future No Legacy no history no purpose
you are chained to your base desires
um Elita of rock and rolla in 2020
there's one million abortions Pearl if
you even prevent one that is priceless
thank you sentience to the [ __ ] in the
middle of the couch you are not
masculine you lack boundaries and
deluded yourself into being feminine she
is sharing her most intimate Parts with
other men and thus gives you
and thus nothing she gives you is
intimate or private she's not special a
marriage causes divorce blonde guy is
very smart marriage is weird wizard
eight beta male doesn't have the same
sexual standards as a physically and
mentally dominant man next to him who do
poly relationships are for women check
the definition of [ __ ] again 90 free
Tope at Sarah tell her she's being
Whimsical again Gus modern women modern
women cause sexual and relationship
attraction men and women are not the
same the majority of men who want other
men to don't want other men to F their
wife or their girl bossy dude in the
middle gets pegged for sure the UK
Economist it's simple a financial
provider would typically care about her
body count Lower earning men who want a
50 50 relationship wouldn't care
sentience the redhead always brings up
exceptions to the rule rather than in
being introspective and genuine she is
disagreeable to the point of being
argumentative and masculine enough to
have narcissistic levels of needing to
be right The Wanderer No Cap I have a
girlfriend that that insists I open up
emotionally I did it it felt good I
won't lie but a few months in she
admitted she found me less attractive
wizardate ape communim uses idiots to
gain a foothold for big government to
support displaced people then that then
take from the working class and creates
a system where small businesses
individually fail sentience the
delusional redhead 304 is emphasizing
Equity rather than equality having equal
outcomes regardless of effort quickly
shows that people don't have to strive
to do better because the outcomes are
the same thus preventing Innovation or
Progress
nas009 Red is talking about the
indoctrination of the woke agenda The
Savvy Ninja
the system this girl is seeking is
called the Bible if you read and follow
even 60 of what it says what it says you
would save yourself from a lot of pain
zentians oh look delusional redhead is
back you want to undo biology the
statement is ignorant and arrogant
claims basic claiming housing is the
basic human rights shows you lack
knowledge of what a right versus
privileges shelter is a need not a right
um Armstrong housing is a basic human
right WTF go to my laws in the
Philippines and say that you're going to
be laughed at food shelter and
companionship are earned not owned Kilt
and Daniel ain't not but about
accountability
um
for I don't know how to pronounce this
username at 86. this fake redhead yet
again doesn't think logically or even
realistically though LMAO Pearl I love
your content wizard 8 Pro you make me
want to be a better man when can I get
in your show and ruthlessly hit on you
um how is Cheryl Matchmaker here Bakers
get with Bakers Etc Pearl's archetypes
are administrator Entertainer and keeper
mad scientist ish helper Warrior Tech
competitive Innkeeper Entertainer
Pearl's match would be uh
Rosenberg type issues would be a jamella
I have no idea what you just said
um Jeremy any man who wants to attain a
highly disciplined life needs any man
who wants to attain a highly disciplined
life needs to practice nofap I'm Dave
thieves I would suggest that single
mothers raise men that women don't want
most of the kids today are products of
single mother homes it's empowering
disregard entire future generations for
your Liberation sentience men should not
have female friends unless they are gay
then focus on female relationships as
wasted when a guy said he should focus
on himself and self-improve to the point
of finding a sexual partner
um okay guys I can't go through all of
these
that's what you're supposed to do
oh gosh okay let me I'll do I'll do a
couple more bro just shave it off you're
almost there anyway Kendra Scott geez I
never heard of blue balls before men
need needs a release medically
um young Lex how is it so hard to
understand that humans who a human being
who isn't having a basic sexual need met
is an unhealthy let alone a man with 50
times more testosterone kilton Daniels
they are not getting experience the
warmth of a glazed donut marriage causes
divorces both men and women can be 304s
but a man 304 is a highly successful a
woman 304 equals baggage trauma daddy
daddy issues in a low sexual market
value bluntly speaking prison is an
example for Sarah's Point guys and girl
prisons can turn out by the same gender
in a matter of months
um Harvest 207 boxers without sex get
aggressive dc-081 to The Woman in Red
saying right after your statements is in
to The Woman in Red saying right after
your statements in an argument doesn't
mean you're correct secondly please
remember the bra most in 1938 question
for the panel what would what would be
the effect in the west if we adopted the
concept of Dowry
um kilton Daniels ran through with a
semi-truck trailer hitch choo choo Bosie
dude in the middle took the comments
well if only his hair was as thick as
his skin zero Fallout trust me bro I've
slept with a lot of women NH to the guy
that contradicted himself with the story
about his dad wanting him to be abortion
boarded and his mom choosing to keep
after saying it's absurd to the argument
that women have more power see blue the
most beta guy on the panel the guy on
the couch put your socks on oh okay I
think that's all of them we done
um I think there's going to be more but
you just go around do final thoughts
yeah guys girls ladies females whatever
you is you choose to be cool nowadays
um
yeah let's get some final thoughts
before we finish based on the topic or
based on the topic yeah anything else
you want to find all things you just
want to get off your chest now is yeah
um
I believe that
if we were to kind of understanding
where people come from when they're in
certain situations that make them want
to sleep around that make them want to
do certain things
um I feel like we should just accept
that people are on their own Journeys
so this is not what I want to say I feel
like I got put on the spot a little bit
there all right you could be last if you
want we could rewind and come again yeah
right now let me all right let's let's
do this yeah that'd be great okay
you got nothing to say not really no no
no it's been an interesting little it's
been an interesting little conversation
we've all had and um
and we can just agree too yeah yeah we
can agree with this great
um and I I've yeah I've appreciated it
fair enough my apologies if I've had all
been do not apologize
you're yourself go on
um I just wish we had more time to talk
I have like so much to say on a lot of
these topics and I didn't want to
interrupt everyone else but you should
have
I just blow everyone away with all the
stuff how long are you in London until
tomorrow
come back tomorrow
evening or tomorrow afternoon okay okay
oh okay you'd have to do an extended cut
right now and then we'll just
get everything out if you want to let
people know
where to follow you or anything
um yeah you guys can follow me on
Instagram uh real Luis Mercado
it's pretty much you find everything
else from there fair enough cool yeah I
mean to conclude I don't think there's
anything wrong with that so being a hoe
just like don't expect to get married
don't expect to find like high value guy
who wants to settle down with you
and um yeah just men in general tend to
be more attracted to feminine
youthful women who don't have a lot of
baggage
yeah and if you guys want to follow some
of my content I have a YouTube channel
where I talk about a lot of this stuff
uh I'm gonna follow you yeah it's just
my name Justin Mark Marc Justin Mark I
also have a podcast actually it's called
the wingman podcast if you just YouTube
search the women podcast I talk about a
lot of these Concepts
and um yeah thanks for having me guys my
Instagram is uh drunk Justin too so you
guys can follow me there as well
we can go back to you because you said
you didn't win it yeah so I I am fully
aware of the fact that sometimes I can
be a bit Whimsical in My Views but it is
genuinely because I want to see a
society that works towards the best for
everyone and so the reason I enjoy being
in these spaces is to have these
conversations to kind of try and figure
out how we can do that and I don't
believe that is through dictating the
way other people can live their lives I
think there's a lot of ways that we can
build a successful society and we have
to allow people in a space to find their
own roles and I think the issue is that
we're forcing people into spaces and so
then they act out as a result of being
restricted so yeah I know I'm really
grateful to be here my band is releasing
our song
um it's called glass Bridges uh glass
Bridges Probably sounds different in an
English accent
um glass bridge is UK that's the one yes
that's it
um we'll be releasing our first single
in October
um and then also I'll be releasing some
of my own music at the end of the year
as well so you can follow me at I am
simono cutefani you can spell it again
you know I'm just gonna say listen
if you have watched two or more
of our videos tell them
tell them and you haven't subscribed
uh-huh then we have what beef what have
we got bro beef okay so if you haven't
done that do it right now
um follow me at Sarah Garvey on all
social medias
um thank you all for tuning in I'm gonna
let Pearl close out the show
okay guys
um you already know go subscribe to our
two clips channels that we have going I
think we're gonna do a third Clips
Channel too this month so watch out for
that
um also don't forget to sign up for our
memberships we let everyone in the chat
today but we will be turning it to
members only next stream
um you also can do our second tier which
you get our first behind the scenes look
at the pet house which is cool right
yeah yeah this is a nice nice place yeah
it's nice
um you'll also see we had we had a
little housewarming party so there's
like a vlog coming uh I should post that
on my like on my YouTube not until I put
it on the members
um also um third tier you get to connect
with us on social media fourth tier you
get a one-on-one call with me once a
month this can be used you know if you
want advice or or if you want to start a
YouTube channel I can also help you with
that too so one-on-one call once a month
um also don't forget to subscribe to the
channel I think my my this stuff keeps
dying today but I think we hit 350 Subs
this stream
so don't forget to subscribe to the
channel like the video on your way out
and we will talk to you next time